welcome to bit by bit a series where we
highlight one thing you can do to
optimize and run a bit better in Google
Cloud today's topic stabilizing your
workloads by tuning requests in
kubernetes
optimization isn't only centered around
cost but on the ability for your
workloads to operate with reliable
performance
kubernetes has a built-in quality of
service model that is inferred from how
you set workload requests and limits and
based on our research it is most
critical to understand the reliability
implications of your requests especially
when they are not set at all
so let's walk through them
[Music]
we recently published the state of
kubernetes cost optimization report
which you can find Linked In the
description below and this was focused
on identifying patterns from clusters
that perform well in managing costs
without compromising workload
reliability and actually our biggest
finding in that research came from the
lens of workload reliability in that we
observe far more workloads without any
requests in than we expected so let's
demo why this could be a threat to
workload reliability using this
deployment called no requests it of
course has no requests set it runs a
container to produce CPU and memory
stress and so now let's run a group CTL
command to filter for pods that are in a
bad state in this case evicted out of
memory killed error or container status
unknown
[Music]
once we run that what we'll actually
find is that we have a whole bunch of
our no request pods that are troubled
to investigate the cause let's describe
one of the pods with an evicted status
so we'll just grab this last one and see
what happened
so as we scroll up here we can see that
this pod was evicted due to memory
pressure
this means that the node that the Pod
was running on was actually very scarce
on available memory due to other
workloads running on that note
because this pod set no requests
kubernetes assigned at the lowest
quality of service best effort which
makes it very likely to be one of the
first to be evicted to free up memory
when eviction happens because of node
pressure there's no respect for pod
disruption budgets or even termination
grace period seconds now in this case
eviction was actually performed by the
Cuba in cases where the cubelet can't
evict pods fast enough then the
underlying host out of memory killer
will actually step in To Kill The
Container process and this also takes
into account the quality of service
class in the score that it uses to
choose processes to kill now all of this
spells trouble for end users of
workloads that are unintentionally not
setting requests so the first thing we
want to do across teams is actually
drive awareness as to what these
workloads might be so gke our team has
actually built a dashboard for workloads
at risk this is directly integrated into
Cloud monitoring so if we navigate there
we can search for the gke workloads at
risk dashboard
foreign
is a top level view of all the workloads
in our GK clusters in this project and
so immediately we can see the percentage
of workloads that don't have CPU or
memory set we can also see the
percentage of workloads that are under
provision right so this means that
they're using a lot more than they
actually request in kubernetes and for
memory especially we can see that this
is also a reliability risk of
this puts them at the burstable quality
of service class and in times of memory
pressure could also make them candidates
to be evicted or turn
and if we jump down to the best effort
section we can see that the queries are
actually already pre-populated so we
don't have to do anything they're
available in the dashboard as soon as we
open it and if you look below you can
see that we actually see a deployment
resource and the sum of usage in memory
that it has across all of its pods and
the same goes for CPU right we have the
queries already pre-built so we can
basically get a deeper understanding of
all of our best effort workloads and how
much they're really using when requests
aren't set the dashboard also has a
bursible workload section where we can
see workloads that are running well
above the request so you can actually
see the percentage of usage against the
requests
of course there are times where we may
just see a pot of trouble and we just
want to understand maybe the start
what's its quality of service so if we
grab and run group CTL to get our out of
memory killed pods and actually
um you know run this Coupe CTL get pod
command and look for the status qos
class value and we'll see that yes this
indeed is the best effort top if you
want to do this at scale we have a very
um
or not at scale but across your entire
cluster and this is enough to be a gke
cluster but we have a simple CLI called
Cube request Checker where it's a basic
script that you could use to list all
the containers that you have in your
cluster that don't have requests in it
so you can see here that our stress
containers for auto remote request
deployment doesn't have CPU and memory
requests
and so all of this is really the Genesis
of beginning to find that balance
between cost optimization and workload
reliability so if you want to learn more
about it I encourage you to not only
check out the dashboard that I showed
earlier but also our report that we
published in June 2023 where we talk a
lot about this
to recap it is critical that you make
sure you have requests set for your
workload if you already have them set
but you're setting them too low
specifically on memory it's also
critical to set memory requests equal to
limits to ensure your workload does not
get disrupted as always you can learn
more at the links in the description
below and we'll see you in a bit
[Music]